so
question uh who's ready for a flashback
to 12
years ago
[Music]
so i recently have been kind of
reflecting on my youtube career and it's
safe to say that i think that i'm
officially old like i cannot even
believe the fact that my youtube channel
that i started in 2006 there are people
watching my channel right now they were
not even born when i started my channel
like that to me is absolutely
mind-blowing and why it's so shocking to
me is because my attention span is
pretty much non-existent so the fact
that something can hold my attention for
that long still to this day i absolutely
love it and have been really enjoying
seeing this entire space just evolve
like right before my eyes and it's
evolved over the past
oh my goodness
what is that what is the math on that
like 16 years how many years has it been
since may of 2006. oh yes uh 16. like
some of you who are starting to drive
right now like i was starting a youtube
channel and about 12 13 years ago i
started this show called ask ij it was
kind of like the beginning of ask me
question videos so i thought today in
honor of that i would answer some of
your questions i've already
screenshotted some that i asked you guys
on twitter if you want to follow me on
twitter at ijustine oh my god this is so
weird i feel like i'm just kind of time
traveling back to the first episode of
ask ig watching this old video of the
first episode of ask ij is honestly kind
of shocking because i'm just picturing
the studio apartment that i had my
studio that i'm shooting this video in
right now is larger than that entire
apartment combined my bedroom my kitchen
my bathroom like it was a very very
small apartment so it's so strange kind
of sitting here many years later to
really kind of reflect on how grateful i
am to really be able to to be doing this
for so long and i don't really think
about it that often to kind of think of
like where i started and where i am now
and
that's a very long time to be doing
something so if any of you are currently
working on a project or you want to do
something in the future like sometimes
things take a very long time there's ups
there's downs and my journey to here
there has been so many ups and downs
things that i've never shared publicly
on the internet and it's just kind of
interesting because i've sort of crafted
this
entire strange career from the very
beginning and who knows where i'll be in
10 years which somebody actually asked
me one of those questions without
further ado i want to hop into some of
these questions okay zach wants to know
will you include the original theme song
of course didn't you just hear it jeff
smith thank you so much for that
original piece of art it is such an
iconic song emily is asking what the
favorite thing is about my job and
actually it's ironic that she would ask
this because i got a chance to meet
emily back at vlog university she has
been following my channel for the past
couple of years and it's so awesome to
really get a chance to meet you guys
like the people that see my content you
watch my videos you watch whatever it is
that you're watching of mine follow me
on instagram follow me on twitter
whatever it is and then i actually get
to meet you guys in person and that was
honestly like the coolest part about my
job is seeing you guys in person seeing
the impact that i've had on some of your
lives and like that is so incredibly
meaningful because i never really had i
guess a role model when i was growing up
of someone who was doing something that
i wanted to do there weren't many women
in tech there really wasn't many women
at all that i knew doing the types of
things that i liked like playing video
games editing coding and now with the
internet like you can find people who
are doing things that you like and you
can follow them and you can talk to them
and you can reach out so the fact that
like i can be that for some of you out
there is so freaking awesome and it
honestly means the world to me so thank
you again for watching and however you
guys found my channel or found me i
appreciate you and you're all so awesome
and i'm so excited that i get to do this
for a job it is a very very difficult
job i don't think a lot of people
understand how difficult it is but it is
something that i genuinely really do
enjoy and
i am so excited for the next question
which is from mike craza hello mike oh
my god it's so good to hear from you as
well how many external hard drives did
you have to go through to find that
original theme song thankfully gmail i
had it in my email i just did a quick
little
and there it was this is so awesome
seeing so many of you guys from back in
the day greg who said well i think i was
a part of that first ask ij so i got to
keep it going what are some of the
similarities that you're seeing between
the rise of social media boom in 2006
and the rise of the nft market now i
would say
the nft market is so much more volatile
than social media back then just because
there is money at stake there are so
many more scammers and there's so many
more people on the internet that have
access to these types of things that you
have to be super super careful but the
thing that i am excited about in the nft
in the crypto in the blockchain in the
web3 space is what the future
of that is going to look like like right
now there are environmental impacts but
what i am most excited about is the
future of what this space looks like
with web3 with the blockchain tech with
nft technology now i know it's such a
huge controversy but i promise you as
someone who has been criticized in the
past for being made fun of for playing
video games i used to go to lan parties
some of my friends in high school back
in the 90s were competing in
gaming tournaments and we were getting
made fun of they're like video games
you're never gonna actually be able to
professionally play that and make it a
career that's weird because then i was
hosting call of duty tournaments where
the prize pool was a million dollars so
went from getting made fun of for
playing video games to hosting million
dollar tournaments oh let me remember
the times that i had people tell me that
their friends were making fun of me for
making youtube videos back in 2006 and
it's very interesting because some of
those people who i remember were making
fun of me were asking for collabs many
years later interesting so with people
making fun of me for my interest in web
3 nft blockchain tech i get it i
understand where you're coming from
because it is something that is
completely new there are a ton of things
that are wrong with it but that is how
things start there are environmental
impacts especially with ethereum and how
much processing power it takes to
actually mine ethereum a lot of this
tech that is so early right now it will
be used in future iterations of what
web3 will become and what you currently
see it now i know i know the right click
save jpegs the screenshot whatever with
a lot of these future iterations of
ethereum like ethereum 2.0 and even
solana these will all be consuming way
less energy so a lot of those
environmental impacts of things that we
have currently those will hopefully all
be taken care of i know a lot of people
have a lot of strong opinions about it
they either love it or they hate it i
feel like there's no kind of middle
ground and the interesting thing is a
lot of the information that people are
saying is it's a lot of
not true things would you guys like to
see me kind of explain my thought
process in sort of this web 3 space in
the crypto in the nft world and i'm not
going to be giving you any financial
advice like i'm not saying go out and
buy these i'm not telling you to start
investing in crypto i just want to
kind of dispel i think some of the myths
and some of the misconceptions because i
think that's one of the things that's
kind of upsetting is a lot of people
don't have all of the information and
when you go to sort of look up this
information it's really hard to find
because everything is so polarizing and
i would say that if this is something
that you are interested in you have to
do your research you need to find
trusted people because there are a lot
of scams there's scams everywhere i mean
if you look in my youtube comments it's
basically a ton of bots just spamming
and scamming and that is nothing new but
it is very very prevalent in the nft
space and it is very easy to get scammed
i unfortunately was scammed and i'm
actually glad that i was because i
learned from that experience but i am
super excited about some of these new
platforms and some of the blockchain
tech that is coming out that is
environmentally friendly there are so
many ways that this could actually be
achieved i am just very excited to kind
of see where it all goes so i know that
was kind of like a long-winded answer
but i honestly do truly believe that
there is something here is
the current form that it's in now it no
is it flawed yes that goes with
basically the entire beginning of social
media that's the fun part and what i
think is so cool about web3 is the
community aspect of like we all kind of
have the ability to help make these
changes and i'm just really excited to
kind of see the next generation kind of
take this to a whole other level like
you guys are the next generation so like
what are you guys going to create that
isn't created now like when people say
hey i want to be a youtuber yeah cool
great why don't you strive to do
something that is not even here yet and
i feel like that has been something that
i've done
pretty much my entire life i've found
really cool small platforms like twitter
like instagram and all of these things
before there were tons of people on it
and that's why it's so exciting to see
people kind of creating new platforms
every single day that could potentially
be the future anyway that was i don't
even know did i answer your question
that's hard to say um nico is saying you
made this intro 13 years ago oh my god
look at that
wow oh my gosh rob is showing his you
can ask ij t-shirt can you even believe
this
wow also want to know if this was going
to include the original theme song yup
you better believe it i don't think ask
ij shirts are still available but i mean
if you guys really want me to revamp
that incredible design i can do that
connor's asking if i will ever
no that's not what he's asking at all
actually he said do you think we'll see
apple launch their multi-reality headset
this year and if so what would you like
to see it do wow i guess i would like it
just to be comfortable i mean i think
that's one of the things that's really
difficult for a lot of these headsets is
they are heavy they're kind of bulky and
i get motion sickness very very easily
so if there's some way to kind of limit
the motion sickness aspect like i'm all
for it i think obviously having it be
cordless is a huge plus long battery
life and comfort we need to have it be
comfortable and i feel like once apple
does this they're gonna do it right my
dream podcast guess for same brain i
mean i guess it would be tim cook but
like i already talked to him but if he
wants to come back on and chat like any
time like for an extended period of time
tim you know
where to find us
how's my tesla model s plaid is it
better than the mercedes that i had so
they're like very like two very separate
cars i absolutely love the model s plaid
i actually was thinking of selling my
mercedes but it is completely paid off
and i love that car so much and i feel
like the only way that i will get rid of
that is if i am upgrading to i like a
truck or something like that because i
feel like i do a lot of lugging of gear
a lot of stuff and so having that larger
vehicle especially one that is paid off
i'm not worried about that car for me
has already kind of had its little dents
and mix so like i don't mind taking that
off-roading and going places and not
worrying about like oh my god my tesla
model s plaid like i can't take that
off-road but mercedes suv yep i can take
that anywhere fastest rubik's cube
solving time dennis you're asking a lot
of hit questions um it's under three
minutes maybe like 2
40 something do i still play animal
crossing yes i do
i haven't been playing as much but i
still
play like a couple times a week for sure
krishna is
talking about a q a that i did from lax
if you remember some 12 or 13 years ago
my flight was delayed i actually do
remember that we were discussing food
choices in various terminals that sounds
about accurate ravi what was your vision
for the channel at this particular point
and that is a picture of me and my
teenage mutant ninja turtles costume
running around my yard 15 years ago
that's cool love that you'd love to see
that you love to see it nicholas says
you've accomplished so much since the
start of your youtube channel where do
you see yourself 12 years from now oh my
god i don't know my i'm i don't know
that's such a long time that's such a
long time favorite apple product i mean
it's gotta be my phone like my iphone
like i can literally do everything from
this every thing favorite games to play
over the past year oh man i haven't like
really done any crazy playthroughs
except for halo i played that so much
over the christmas break and basically
me and my sister were in opposite rooms
across from each other in the hall at
our childhood home playing halo and it
felt just like the good old days oh so
great yami alex 224 says i'm 30 and i've
been watching you since the peanut
butter and jelly in the blender and
apple why you know send me phone that's
a long time i remember ordering they
were like the iphone 4 maybe and ups
sent it in an empty box there was no
phone in said box do i think i'll write
another book in the future i think i
will maybe a children's book
will i ever go to another concert again
um i would like to there's actually a
justin bieber concert coming up at the
end of the month but i was thinking that
maybe that might be something that i
would be into my favorite dog breed is
um it's my dog whatever whatever he is
dj minnie matt matty my baby boy he's a
bijon
poodle lhasa apso
chihuahua little mixed mutt and he is
freaking perfect and i think that was
actually the last question that i have
it is
wow uh well thank you guys for watching
this
little ask ij episode i can't believe
i've been doing this for
probably half of some of your lives it's
kind of shocking uh let me know in the
comments below if you have any other
questions i would love to chat with you
guys here after this video was even
posted you know like in the comment
section just like the good old days if
you guys haven't subscribed please hit
subscribe be sure to hit the bell so
you'll be notified when i post new
videos or maybe even some youtube shorts
if you guys are into that sort of thing
i'll see you guys later bye
[Music]
uh